I apologize for the absurd philosophical
question but if an alien species were to
visit earth do you think we would be
able to find a common language or
protocol of communication with them
there are arguments to the effect that
we could in fact one of them was Marvin
Minsky's back about 20 or 30 years ago
he performed the so a brief experiment
with a student of his day and Barbara
were they essentially ran the simplest
possible Turing machines just free to
see what would happen and most of them
crashed either got into an infinite loop
for blah stopped the few that persisted
essentially gave something like
arithmetic and his conclusion from
though was that if some alien species
developed higher intelligence they would
at least have arithmetic they would at
least have what the simplest computer
would do and in fact the he didn't know
that at the time but the core principles
of natural language are based on
operations which yields something like
arithmetic in the limiting case and a
minimal case so it's conceivable that a
mode of communication could be
established based on the core properties
of human language and the core
properties of arithmetic which maybe are
universally shared so it's conceivable
you